if you were to walk onto any film or tv
set right now
you might think it were some kind of
medical drama nope
that's just the reality of showbiz in
the time of covid
tests masks scheduling delays hollywood
is seeing it all
how did zendaya manage to film what
she's calling a very special project
during quarantine
which actors have contracted covid19
while filming
curious as to how it's happening we've
got the scoop in real life they probably
scrub for a little bit longer
on tv we do it pretty quick as long as
the dialogue takes while many of us were
binge watching all the zendaya content
we could find
she was busy on set for not one but two
films
what a queen the first movie was malcolm
and marie which was filmed entirely
during the pandemic over 14 days and 14
nights
the cast and crew remained in a bubble
shooting in a secret location
zendaya collaborated with euphoria
creator sam levenson
because she was really missing creating
art they quietly devised a plan so they
could do the shoot safely
this meant having a small cast and crew
all of whom took on multiple roles
much of the clothing used in the film
belonged to zendaya who also did her own
hair and makeup
that is no small feat on top of all this
the actress went on to start shooting
spider-man 3.
we can't wait to see her work in the
upcoming spider-man and her very special
quarantine project
malcolm and marie set to hit netflix
this february
you ready yeah you're gonna love this
our favorite spider-man
tom holland has been busy sporting a
double mask on set these days
the actor has been promoting coveted
safety via his social media since he's
been on set in atlanta where the next
spider-man is being filmed we just
landed in atlanta
it's time for spider-man 3. let's go
some people have been speculating
whether or not the film will take place
in the pandemic world filled with masks
and social distance
it's more likely the creators are
adjusting the timeline and setting it a
bit into the future when the pandemic
isn't as prevalent throughout society
holland has said that this production
has really brought him full circle as
atlanta
is the place that he first auditioned
for the role dude by movie three
you're gonna have your stun double be
doing that i'm like no no no no
chris pratt had just started filming
jurassic world three
only to have the production shut down
shortly after due to the pandemic
the crew went to work to make sure the
filming could resume with all the safety
measures in place some of these included
the cast and crew getting electronic
temperature checks before they're even
allowed on set
everything seemed to be going well until
someone on set contracted covet 19.
after another break filming finally
finished 18 months after
they began the whole process has been
quite trying on pratt since he hasn't
been able to spend time with his family
like zendaya pratt has also been pulling
double duty traveling to australia to
film the next thor movie
love and thunder part of the protocol
he's undergone there was completing a
14-day quarantine
chris pratt decided to spend some time
in isolation going through
unopened emails the riverdale star was
part of the first film to be shot in la
during quarantine
not only was songbird filmed during
covid but it didn't shy away from taking
on pandemic themes
the movie starring appa and sophia
carson is set in 2024 where the pandemic
continues to loom with a mutated version
of coronavirus called covid23
for the sake of authenticity the film
looks at a romantic relationship
developed between two people who can't
meet because of quarantine restrictions
definitely a true depiction of what life
is like while the movie is technically
considered a thriller carson said at its
core
the movie is about hope an extraordinary
experience to be able to
not only to work in the middle of this
but to channel everything that we've all
been feeling
anne hathaway has been at work during
the pandemic across the pond in the uk
filming locked down a very aptly named
flick
the movie is another on the list of
those that have been filmed entirely
during the pandemic
like the film songbird it also depicts
life during coronavirus
following the struggles of a
relationship of an estranged couple
stuck together during the crisis a major
plot point is the plan to steal a 4
million
diamond from herod's department store
the pandemic has offered a unique
opportunity
since this is the first film to ever
have scenes shot inside herod's
if the famous store weren't closed right
now they wouldn't have been able to
the building isn't the only way herons
plays a role in the film though
actual employees from the store were
used as extras
this production came up with all sorts
of creative ways to make the movie a
reality
including the director flying himself to
london in a propeller plane
some actors film their scenes via
laptops it's
crazy to think the entire filming
process was orchestrated in just
three weeks it's one of those moments
where you're like nobody gets this
like nobody gets to do this zoe saldana
is one of the many actors who continued
to work during the pandemic
filming in new zealand she has been busy
with the new avatar films
which didn't have to change their
schedules around too much since they
were already meant to spend time
shooting in new zealand
luckily the country has been really
great with controlling the number of
cases and spread of course
everyone had to quarantine for a
two-week period and continue to follow
very strict covet protocols
sort of sit back and watch what happens
in avatar but i really think that jim
will not fail to deliver
the anticipated film the batman starring
our favorite vampire robert pattinson
has had quite the eventful time filming
after shooting
only about a quarter of the movie they
had to stop due to the pandemic
once there were protocols and safety
measures put in place and filming
resumed
another hurdle came up according to an
inside source
pattinson tested positive for kovid this
delayed the project release by a few
months
after waiting for some time the movie
started up with filming again
after some time disaster struck after a
stuntman on
set tested positive as well more delays
resulted in the release date being
pushed to march 2022
we can only imagine how frustrating and
strenuous the process would have been
for this cast and crew
another marvel flick has been busy at
work during the pandemic
but not without its fair share of delays
and struggles
doctor strange starring elizabeth olsen
wound up stopping filming
in part because it's such a large and
complicated production
the movie was being filmed in the uk
where covered numbers and a new strain
have been on the rise
the hospitals wound up filling up so
they halted filming for safety
olson expressed the difficulty that has
come with filming and the fact that
she'd gone through
the second lockdown i've experienced in
three months
in london also marking two significant
delays in the production schedule
while each film is following the
recommended safety protocols
major productions like this film are
difficult to bring to life
ben affleck has had quite the touch and
go schedule for the movie hypnotic
the production began in la but had to
stop deuterizing covet numbers
the team began considering doing the
movie in texas until the numbers there
began rising as well
finally they settled on moving the
production up north to vancouver
canada choosing to go with solstice
studios was a safer bet as the testing
was more readily accessible and the
cases weren't as bad as they were in the
states
one of the major departments being
affected by the pandemic has been the
budget
an extra two million dollars had to be
added to the already huge cost to ensure
all safety protocols could be upheld
properly
on top of it all the team ran into some
trouble with their insurance around
kovid and is currently in the midst of a
lawsuit
it's very frustrating it's very
difficult it's very competitive
ellen pompeo also known as meredith gray
has been used to working with medical
equipment regularly on the long-running
medical drama grey's anatomy
the show was filming their 16th season
and on march 12th
everything came to a halt the unofficial
finale wound up airing
leaving everyone wondering what would
happen when they started up again
since the show has always prided itself
in accurately portraying the medical
world
they dove right into depicting the real
world as it goes through the pandemic
they've been extra diligent about
keeping cast and crew safe by testing
everyone regularly
the set is filled with sanitizers and
masks for regular use
and not just set dressing while pompeo
has been the center of many dramatic
plots
she's definitely never faced anything
like covet 19.
one of the major protocols the team has
been practicing is dividing the cast and
crew into different zones
depending on which zone they're in they
get tested a certain amount of times
not only is the crew in full ppe but we
are as well because we get to play
doctors
tom hanks was the first major celebrity
to be diagnosed with covet 19.
the actor was in australia shooting an
elvis presley biopic
until he was hospitalized with the virus
the production came to a halt while he
and his wife reed wilson recovered
once the production was ready to begin
filming again hanks was required to
quarantine when he arrived in australia
and was even checked on by police during
the two weeks
to make sure he was following the rules
hanks being the amazing person he is
has donated his plasma to researchers to
help with learning more about the virus
how do you feel about the pandemic
themed movies
share your thoughts with us in the
comments section make sure to hit
subscribe to keep up with all our
content
you